on book TV eco economy is a new book by
Lester Brown next you can see the
worldwatch institute founder and
chairman as he calls for harmony between
the economy and natural resources
according to mr. Brown our current
profit focused economic model is
untenable depleting forests oil farmland
top soil water atmosphere and species
beyond a sustainable level he recommends
policy tools to reverse this trend
including a restructuring of the tax
system that will simultaneously reduce
income taxes and raise taxes on
environmentally destructive activities
the event from the Washington DC branch
of the english-speaking Union is an hour
in 20 minutes
good evening as most of you know most of
you have the doubtful distinction of
knowing me as president of the local
branch of the Washington branch of the
english-speaking Union but it's a
distinct honor to be here tonight and to
welcome you all as all of you know the
mission of the english-speaking union is
to promote the English language not in
the monolithic fashion not English only
but rather interestingly not everybody
knows this i think the most graphic
example of the growth of the
english-speaking union is in countries
that used to be behind the Iron Curtain
countries for whom English is a second
language and it has always seemed to me
the pursuit to pursue this mission with
any rational analysis one should try to
connect our membership with the
prominent thinkers of our era addressing
crucial issues there are two that begin
with II one of them's in the environment
and one of them is education and we are
having a very distinguished education
panel next monday evening februari the
fourth and i bring this to our attention
because as with the environment the
challenges and prospects are very
complex there are a number of
significant trade-offs that have to be
made in the world of education as they
are on the world of environment and
therefore it's a distinct privilege to
ask John Andrews elegant executive
director to introduce our featured
speaker of this evening Lester Brown
John
Thank You Graham I believe the Graham
was a bit too modest to introduce
himself this was rammed down a noted
educator and we're very proud to say the
president of the Washington branch of
the english-speaking Union for those of
you who may be watching on c-span we'd
like for you to know that we are on
Dupont Circle in Washington at a
historic setting known as the washington
club one of the only buildings perhaps
the only building in our nation's
capital that was designed by architect
Stanford White and we're here for what I
think is a very auspicious occasion and
for me it's a great honor to be able to
welcome Lester Brown our speaker for a
little more than a decade between the
mid 80s and the mid 90s lesson I were
neighbors in a building not far from
here that was on one occasion described
by The Washington Post as a condo with
soul
I don't know how many of you are
familiar with the valley vista but it
was actually a very apt description of
it what I didn't realize however until
around this time one January in the mid
80s was just how important my neighbor
was and what gave me that revelation was
the column called the presidency in Time
magazine by Hughes IT and it was during
the week when readers of time would
normally expect to have a discussion of
the state of the union address on this
occasion mr. side he felt that there was
a more important topic to deal with and
that was the state of the planet and
there was a picture of a familiar face
and a story about Lester Brown less is
the recipient at latest count I think of
22 honorary doctorates I may have missed
one or two along the way the most recent
one of which was at Ohio State
University where he was alongside Bill
Cosby on the platform he has also
garnered garnered such prestigious
laurels as a 1986 MacArthur Genius award
the 1987 United Nations Environment
prize and the 1994 blue blue planet
prize a one that carries a purse of five
hundred thousand dollars what is
interesting about less is that he always
turns these awards right into back to
the organization that is really his
whole life in 1974 with support from the
Rockefeller Brothers fund Lester Brown
founded the worldwatch institute its
annual state of the world reports which
commenced in 1984 are now available and
i believe 30 languages around the world
so this is an illustration of one of the
points that Graham is making about the
globalization
of so many aspects of our life these
days in May of 2001 after becoming
chairman of the world watch board Lester
Brown established a new organization a
think-tank known as the earth policy
institute and the subject of tonight's
address will be the first book-length
publication of the earth policy and
policy institute a book called echo
economy one of my fondest memories of
less occurred I think it was on the 20th
anniversary of Earth Day and he
introduced me to a colleague of his
named dennis hayes and they were they
were planning the celebration and and i
mentioned to mr. Hayes that i had
learned that one thing you didn't ask
less when you greeted him in the morning
was housed the world treating you and he
agreed he said you know if you say that
in the evening there goes the evening
well I willing to take that chance that
I hope you are as well and I hope you'll
join me on a warm welcome to our
distinguished speaker Lester are brown
less
thanks John as John indicated we've
known each other for a while one of my
favorite John Andrews stories is the is
also a coals to Newcastle story a
British publisher some years ago decided
to publish and in cyclic a set of
encyclopedias on Shakespeare the works
and life and times of Shakespeare and
they were looking for a Shakespeare
scholar to edit this set of
encyclopedias and they came to the
United States and John was the editor of
this British set of encyclopedias on
Shakespeare now that has to be closed to
new castle if ever there was one I
appreciate very much the the
introduction John it reminded me of
Oscar Wilde who once said I appreciate
the truth but I much prefer flattery
at least you didn't do what former
Senator Paul Simon of Illinois did when
he was introduced to me once he held up
the book and he said Lester's written
the sort of book that once you put it
down you can't pick it up again
one more Washington book story then
we'll get serious some of you will
remember Liz carpenter who was mrs.
Linden Johnson social secretary and a
very talented woman after the Johnson
years Liz wrote a book called ruffles
and flourishes that was on the
bestseller list for some time and she
was going about the country from city to
city promoting the book and one night in
a hotel lobby in Atlanta met her former
White House colleague Arthur Schlesinger
and Arthur said oh hi ms that was a
great book you a great book of yours I
really enjoyed reading it who wrote it
for you she said well I'm glad you
enjoyed it Arthur who read it to you
in in 1543 another author Nikolai
Copernicus wrote a long treatise that
had the academic title of I think it was
on the movement of celestial spheres and
in this treatise which reflected decades
of research and data gathering on his
part he had a rather radical proposal he
said the idea that the Sun revolves
around the earth is not is not correct
he said the Earth instead revolves
around the Sun now that was kind of hard
for people to take because it was clear
I mean you could see the Sun come up in
the morning and go down at night and it
just but he with that proposal set in
motion a debate between scientists and
theologians that continued for centuries
but he also set the stage for
extraordinary progress in science
because with this new model suddenly the
astronomers could you know things began
to fall into place before they were sort
of forcing things trying to make them
work and having all sorts of problems
set the stage for progress in astronomy
physics a whole range of Sciences we're
in a somewhat similar situation today in
that the debate today is not scientists
and theologians but economists and
ecologists economists see the
environment as a subset of the economy
it's the pollution part and if you spend
enough money you can take care of it
ecologist on the other hand see the
economy as part of the earth's ecosystem
to sort of commercialized part if you
will but there are all sorts of things
happening of great value and importance
that don't get measured and valued in
the marketplace now as one whose
training is in both the natural sciences
and in economics I can sort of
understand
the the origins of this debate but I I
personally see the world as ecologist
see it and if they're right and if the
economy is part of the earth's ecosystem
then it follows that the structure that
economy has to be compatible with the
earth's ecosystem particularly as the
economy continues to grow and depress
against many of the Earth's natural
limits what we're faced with is a
situation that calls for rather dramatic
change basically a restructuring of the
global economy and I'd like to talk
about the reasons for that and then the
nature of that restructuring the
relationship between the global economy
in the earth's ecosystem is an
increasingly stressed one and we read
about that stress in the daily news
headlines collapsing Fisher's shrinking
forests falling water tables eroding
soils disappearing species rising
temperatures ice melting dying coral
reefs rising sea level you know the list
these are all signs of an increasingly
stressed relationship or we can go back
in time and look at some of the early
civilizations as I was working on eco
economy I reread a book by Joseph
Tainter i think is an archaeologist at
the University of New Mexico was
entitled the something like the the
collapse of complex civilizations and he
went back and looked at various
civilizations the very earliest ones up
until fairly recently and he concluded
that in in a number of cases
environmental deterioration seemed to be
underlying the the decline and collapse
of those civilizations
and I won't go through all of them i'll
just mention one which is the the
Sumerians which was one of the earliest
may have been the first civilization
going back I guess close to six thousand
years he was located in what is now
southern Iraq that area today is
wasteland there's almost nothing there
you can still see the the where the old
canals were the irrigation canals you
can still see the remnants of the early
cities they were carefully planned
cities they weren't sprawling they were
nicely designed the Sumerians were a
cutting-edge civilization the first
written language for example they may
have been as excited about that as we
are about the internet they have a
highly productive agriculture based on a
sophisticated irrigation system they
required engineering far beyond anything
that existed anywhere else at the time
but they had one flaw in the design of
their economic system keep in mind that
it was irrigation that produced the
agricultural surplus that permitted some
people to move into cities and to form
the first cities the flaw in the system
was they didn't understand underground
hydrology and when they started damming
the streams the rivers the Tigris
Euphrates to be specific they they
backed up the water and then they
diverted on the land using gravity
through a series of canals and some of
the water was used by crops some
evaporated in the atmosphere some
percolated down and over time the water
that percolated down gradually raised
the water table until eventually it was
within a few feet of the surface and
then they developed the water logging
problem deep-rooted crops didn't develop
properly and as they kept getting closer
to the surface and then got within
inches of the surface then the water
evaporated through into the atmosphere
but the salt in the water in almost all
water has some minerals insulting the
salt didn't evaporate it
traded on the surface and as the salt
level salt concentrations built up wheat
yields began to fall then they
discovered barley was more salt-tolerant
they shifted to barley but then
eventually the same thing happened there
and eventually their food supply
deteriorated and the civilization
collapsed and that's still wasteland
today we have a basic flaw in the design
of our economy as well and that is that
the carbon emissions from burning fossil
fuels is building up in the atmosphere
exceeding the rate at which nature can
fix co2 and we have what we now refer to
as global warming whether it's rising
water tables or rising co2 levels both
have the potential to undermine
civilizations another source of evidence
beyond Lee up and looking at earlier
civilizations is what's happening in
China today China is a big country it
has been developing an extraordinary
rate in the last two decades since 1980
the Chinese economy has increased in
size by at least four fold incomes have
gone up dramatically it's been the
fastest growing economy in the world
over the last two years we never would
have thought that 25 years ago that
China could achieve these sorts of gains
China is developing very rapidly and is
in effect telescoping history so we can
see what happens when large numbers of
people of poor people become rapidly
more affluent we look at China and we
look at some of the policy decisions and
they're basically trying to imitate us
in 1994 they decided they wanted to
develop an automobile transportation
system big industry automobiles and live
like Americans or Europeans
they issued invitation to the major
automobile companies or proposals to
build automobile assembly plants GM and
Volkswagen and Toyota and so forth if
China ever succeeds and having a car in
every garage or maybe to American soil
they consume gasolina same rate we do
they'll need 80 million barrels of oil a
day the world currently is producing
about 76 million barrels of oil a day
and they never go very much higher or
consider paper consumption if paper
consumption in China reaches the US
level per person they will need more
paper than the world produces there go
the world's forests and one can just go
down the line but what becomes clear in
looking at China is that the Western
industrial development model is not
going to work in China if it doesn't
work for China it's not going to work
for India now with more than a billion
people or for the other two billion
people in the developing world so
whether we look at future consumption
trends is poor become rich or if we look
at stresses in the system or we look at
the history of earlier civilizations are
collapsed I think it becomes clear and
we've got to restructure the global
economy the exciting thing is we can now
see how to do it and that's what eco
economy is about how we get from where
we are with our fossil fuel-based
automobile centered throw away a colony
to a new economy where fossil fuels will
be replaced by renewable energy
resources I'll talk more about this
later where automobiles will be replaced
by public transportation in cities and
with bicycles we're looking at a future
where the throwaway economy will be
replaced by a copy
sense of reuse recycle economy and
materials will be used over and over
again comprehensive recycling I'd like
to before describing the new economy I
like to drop back a bit and look at some
of the just elaborate a bit on a few of
the stresses that I mentioned earlier
one is falling water tables water tables
are now falling on every continent we're
simply pumping water faster than the
nature can recharge underground aquifers
through precipitation in under the North
China Plain which produces probably a
third one more of China's wheat harvest
half the wheat actually the water table
is going down about 1.6 meters a year so
that so much five feet or sun and as it
drops farmers are literally chasing the
water table down where you go through
villages in that area and there's a big
sign often outside the village of who
the local well driller is I mean they're
abandoning wells by the thousands by the
tens of thousands each year and drilling
deeper ones but eventually the aquifer
will be depleted
and then we have to begin thinking about
what this means for China and for the
world traditionally we have thought of
water scarcity as being a local problem
but today water scarcity can cross
national boundaries via the
International grain trade Emila straight
the fastest growing grain market in the
world today is North Africa and the
Middle East that beginning with Morocco
Algeria Tunisia Libya Egypt and on
through Iran in that region every
country is facing water shortages and as
water supplies Titan they satisfy the
growing demands and cities and industry
by taking irrigation water from
agriculture they then import grain to
offset that loss of productive capacity
importing grain is the most efficient
way to import water because it takes a
thousand tons of water to produce one
ton of grain so if you're facing water
shortages that's how you import it in
the form of grain last year the water
required to import the grain in North
Africa and the Middle East was roughly
equal the annual flow of the Nile River
so if you want to visualize the water
deficit in that region today it's about
the size of an another nile river
flowing into the region in the form of
imported grain three years ago Iran
eclipsed Japan for decades the world's
leading importer of wheat Iran now
imports more wheat than Japan last year
Egypt moved ahead of Japan I cite these
two countries because they are
indicative of the kinds of shifts that
are beginning to occur
is often said that future wars in the
Middle East are more likely to be fought
over water than over oil and that may be
but it's difficult to win a water war
and my guess is that the competition for
water is more likely to take place in
world grain markets than in then in
terms of across the border conflicts we
look at China for example and the
potential of enormous deficit developing
their as water tables fall my guess is
that before the end of this year we're
going to see China turning to the world
market for substantial quantities of
brain as as the water supply continues
to tighten at some point they're going
to be driven into the world market and
when China comes into the world market
if even if it's only for ten percent of
the grain in contrast to Japan which is
now over seventy percent but China is so
big it's the world's leading grain
consumer by far if they move into the
world market for even a relatively small
share of their total grain supply we
will all know it not necessarily because
we're reading the daily papers but
because it will show up at the
supermarket checkout counter we will
know when China moves into the world
grain market in a major way it will
affect everyone
my colleague at the worldwatch institute
sander Postell has tried to estimate the
amount of overpumping of aquifers in the
world using data for China India the
Middle East and the United States which
is which gets most of the overpumping
though not all of it she estimates rover
pumping each year now by about 160
billion tons of water that's equal to
about 160 million tons of grain at
average world grain consumption of a
third of a ton per person 160 million
tons of grain as the food supply for 480
million people stated otherwise 480
million of us out of the six billion in
the world today are being fed with grain
produced by overpumping aquifers at some
point that will come to an end when the
aquifers are depleted but I think we're
under estimating the water issue and I
think one of these years it's just sort
of going to blow up in her face and run
I'm wonder where it came from I think
there's anything we learned from the
events of September 11th it is that if
you neglect an issue the price can be
very high and that is as true with water
as it is for terrorism following water
tables is one of the stresses between an
expanding global economy which
incidentally has expanded six-fold since
1950 and the earth's ecosystem the
growth in the world economy last year
was greater than the growth in the world
economy during the 19th century the
economy is huge today and even a small
growth three percent or so is huge by
any historical yardstick I think we we
have not yet realized how big the
economy is becoming in how much it's
beginning to press against the Earth's
various capacities so we're looking at
following water tables we're looking at
ice melting
we read here and there about ice melting
in various scientific reports but it's
not until you put all those reports
together as Lisa mast needed at world
watch a couple of years ago that you
realize that the ice is melting almost
everywhere the Arctic Alaska the Rocky
Mountains the Andes the Alps himali asst
be Namath glacier national park in this
country named because huge number of
glaciers there a lot of them are gone
now and the US Geological Service is
projecting I think would win 30 years
there probably won't be any left we'll
have Glacier National Park but no
glaciers or Mount Kilimanjaro
meteorologist at Ohio State University
whose name escapes me at the moment was
doing some research on Kilimanjaro he
projects that within a dozen years the
snow and ice on Kilimanjaro will be gone
and when he published this paper one of
the first two challenges findings was
the minister of tourism in Tanzania
because Tanzania without Kilimanjaro is
just not quite the same I shouldn't say
without kill matoi without the ice and
snow on Kilimanjaro so the ice is
melting the Arctic sea has lost about
forty percent of its ice over the last
35 years you may remember August a year
ago I remember picking up the new york
times on saturday morning in the valley
vista where Jon and I both used to to
live and on the front page was a story
saying that an icebreaker cruise ship
had reached the North Pole only to
discover that it was in open water how
many of you remember that I can't forget
it i mean it's so out of sync with
everything i learned about the North
Pole reading about Admiral Byrd and all
the others are trying to reach the North
Pole bitter cold and ice and so forth
there it is open water if those guys
have been trying to reach the North Pole
all last summer they would have had to
swim the last few miles it's changing I
mean the reality is that we may soon
have shipping routes we may soon have
the Northwest Passage engulfing North
Atlantic up across the top down through
the Bering Straits and on to Japan or
China and what have you what was the
dream of the ER lyrics of the early
explorers will be our nightmare because
if the ice in the Arctic continues to
melt and they're now projections that
within the half century it may be
ice-free during the summertime then we
have to begin thinking about Greenland
as a couple of teams of American
scientists are at NASA Greenland is
three times the size of Texas it has ice
the ice sheet on it in some areas as a
mile and a half thick but Greenland is
in the Arctic sea and if the climate is
changing in the Arctic you say when it's
covered with ice a lot of the sunlight
comes in it bounces back into space but
when the ice and snow is gone then a lot
of thats absorbed and suddenly you get a
warming effect the reason the scientists
are beginning to focus on Greenland is
because if all the ice on Greenland were
to melt and that won't happen overnight
obviously it would raise sea level 23
feet I haven't checked the markers
around here but we'd be pretty close to
sea level right here I think with if sea
levels to rise 23 feet and the political
part of Washington would be underwater
but we have to begin thinking about
these things as possibilities because
we're we're altering a system we don't
understand very well and and we may
reach the point where we can't turn back
during the last century sea level rose
or something like 8 inches and this
century it could raise could go up that
much or even up to a meter according to
the latest projections by the
international panel on climate change
a one meter rise according to a map
published by the World Bank of
Bangladesh would take half of Bangladesh
riceland is the country of 140 million
people then we're faced with new kinds
of issues where do the people go who
live in low-lying areas of the world in
island countries are a lying coastal
regions where do they migrate to these
are the kinds of questions we've not had
to face before on this scale we could
talk about deforestation another sign of
stress and the relationship between the
global economy and the earth's ecosystem
you may remember in the summer of
nineteen ninety eight there was extreme
flooding and the Yangtze River Basin in
China according to Munich reinsurance
Munich ray that keeps tabs on these
things it did 30 1 billion dollars worth
of damage and 120 million people out of
the four hundred million people live in
the Yangtze River Basin were displaced
for at least a brief period of time as a
result of flooding there and the threats
of of inundation so we're looking at a
situation where and the Chinese were
saying at the time this is an act of
nature well it was in a sense but there
was also a human contribution and by
mid-august they began to realize that
and they had a press conference in
Beijing and they said you know we've
lost eighty five percent of the original
tree cover in the Yangtze River Basin
and this is one of the causes of this
record flooding we're going to ban all
tree cutting now no more tree cutting
and then they made a very interesting
statement they said trees standing are
worth three times as much as cheese cut
they were recognizing that forests
provide not only timber they also
provide services and one of those
services is flood control no question
but that those trees are worth more
standing than being sold up so we're
beginning to see some shifts in thinking
I mean this is something that I would
say but when jus Ranji says it in China
and it begins to have have some real
meaning but this is in a sense the
problem we face in the world we are not
the market is not telling the ecological
truth and I'll come back to this in a
minute so we have to restructure the
global economy we can do it we have the
technologies we know how it's not we
have to wait for some scientific
breakthroughs considering energy energy
for example and I'm only going to talk
about wind wind is an abundant resource
in the United States according to the
Department of Energy's National wind
resource inventory three states north
dakota Kansas and Texas have enough
harness table wind energy to satisfying
national electricity needs this is a
huge resource three states out of 50 now
these are the three leading states of
course but China can double its current
electricity generation from wind alone
no problem Europe densely populated with
going offshore out to a depth of 30
meters enough harness above wind energy
satisfy the continents needs we're
looking at something with huge potential
and what we've seen with wind from its
beginnings in California back in the
early 80s the modern wind industry is
that the cost of generation has dropped
dramatically from thirty-five cents
fifteen years ago thirty-five cents a
kilowatt hour 24 cents today and the
cost is still falling when is now
becoming competitive with coal oil
natural gas and in many areas
undercutting them so this this is
exciting now there are two sort of
parallel advances that have occurred two
parallel technological advances have
been occurring in recent years one is in
the design of wind turbines that's made
them so much more efficient the other is
in the evolution of fuel cells
and fuel cell engines for automobiles
because once you get cheap electricity
from wind you can then use it to
electrolyze water and produce hydrogen
hydrogen becomes a way of storing and
transporting wind energy my friend Ken
Lay at Enron
and I were talking about this in August
the beginning of August timing becomes
important the beginning of august and i
said ken over the last several years and
ron has bought to wind companies one in
the US and one in europe wind turbine
manufacturing companies and i said
you've got a lot of natural gas and
taxes at least you did have and you got
pipelines running into the northeast and
the midwest and so forth is it your plan
that one day when the natural gas is
gone you will simply switch the hydrogen
and harness the wind energy in Texas
produce the hydrogen and use the same
system he said that's the long-term
strategy he says not part of the
short-term planned as part of the
long-term strategy so the interesting
thing about low cost electricity from
wind and producing hydrogen is that
hydrogen is the fuel of choice for the
new fuel cell engines that every major
automobile manufacturers working on Bill
Ford has said that he expected to
preside over the demise of the internal
combustion engine now I don't know
what's happening with this great
grandfather I'm sure he's turning over
in his grave but but this is what he
said and and I think it's going to
happen the first companies to be on the
market with fuel cell powered vehicles I
think are going to be Damon or Chrysler
and Honda they both plan to be on the
market in 2003 that's next year now I'm
sure it won't be millions of vehicles
will be you know probably thousands of
the small scale to begin with but but
we're we're getting there we're close
Iceland
is working with a consortium of
corporations led by shell and de Mer de
Mer Chrysler to make Iceland the world's
first hydrogen powered economy Iceland
has a lot of cheap hydropower shell
plans to use that electricity from the
hydropower to electrolyze water and
produce hydrogen de Mer Chrysler sees
Iceland as a place to test its fuel cell
vehicles this year she'll plans to open
the first hydrogen station in Reykjavik
to service the fleet of 80 buses they
have they're going to convert them from
internal combustion to to fuel cell
powered buses this will be the beginning
Singapore signed a contract with British
Petroleum to start not a contract a
letter of intent with British Petroleum
to develop some built some hydrogen
stations in Singapore so we're beginning
to see things happen in this country
just to give you a sense of how this can
unfold farmers and ranchers who owned
most of the wind rights in the country
could one day not only supply most of
the country's electricity but also much
in the fuel to run the national fleet of
automobiles these technological advances
in wind turbines that have dramatically
lowered the cost of wind energy and fuel
cells which are much more efficient than
internal combustion engine in which you
run on hydrogen are setting the stage
for an energy revolution and I don't
think I mean a comprehensive
restructuring of the energy kind I don't
think most people are aware of yet but
it's coming it's coming very fast so we
can do it the technologies are here
they're within range I mean we still
have some work to do on fuel cells but
it's clearly something we can do we
could talk about solar cells they're
roughly a million homes or so in the
world now they get three lectures and
even solar cells in developing countries
in remote villages which are not hooked
up to a grid it is now cheaper to
install solar cells to provide
electricity than it is to build a
centralized power plant and a grid
building grids costs money to distribute
the electricity
in the Indian countries in many
situations in many villages it is now
cheaper to invest in a solar
installation to produce electricity and
it is to buy candles because the monthly
installment payment on the solar
installation is about the same as the
cost of candles same is true in Indian
many villages in India it's not candles
at kerosene for kerosene lamps there so
this technology is beginning to to come
into place so we're looking ahead in an
age of globalization in the energy
sector we're looking at localization a
trend over the last century was to
globalize energy we've all become more
and more dependent on the Middle East
which has over half the world's oil
reserves but now we're looking at a
reversible that moving toward local
energy sources whether its wind or sun
or what have you so an interesting new
development there the key I could talk
for one more minute about materials
policy just to give an idea how things
are beginning to change there is in
Atlanta Georgia a manufacturer of
industrial carpet Industrial carpet is
what you put in office buildings and
factories and so forth and as opposed to
residential carpeting for homes it's
headed by a guy named Ray Anderson he
founded about 25 years ago and he was
converted to environmentalism six or
seven years ago and he began asking
himself what can we do in my company in
my industry to build a sustainable
economy and occurred to him but they
shouldn't be selling carpet they should
be selling carpeting services so they
would contract with Washington Club to
provide certain quality of carpet and so
forth over a ten-year period they would
maintain it and when the carpet wore out
it would go back to the factory the
nylon who melted down again spun into
new fiber died and go back on the floor
someplace our goal Ray Anderson says is
not to lose a single molecule of
carpeting material the interesting thing
about this industrial model is you don't
use any raw material you just keep
recycling the same carpeting nothing
goes to the landfill
so this is the new model for materials
policy of how we think about it I won't
go into more detail but if you want to
see what interface carpeting looks like
come to the earth policy institute on
the other side of the circle we have
interface carpeting on the floor
interestingly it's put down in tiles
about 18 inches by 18 inches so there's
some places of where a lot you can take
them out and replace them you don't have
to take out the whole carpet for example
I mean you don't know that their tiles
because it looks like a solid carpet one
of the keys to building an eco economy
is getting the price right and right now
as I mentioned with the Yangtze River
example and the price of the value of
trees we don't have the prices right for
example if you buy a gallon of gasoline
you pay the cost of getting the oil out
of the ground refining it into gasoline
and delivering it to the service station
you don't pay the cost of the the
additional health care costs of treating
respiratory illnesses from breathing the
polluted air or the damages for acid
rain you don't pay the cost of climate
disruption and displacing millions of
Bangladesh news or what have you so the
key is to get the market to tell the
ecological truth royston dolly I know
Norwegian friend and former vice
president of Exxon for Norway in the
North Sea said a few months ago and I
quote he said socialism collapsed
because it did not allow the market to
tell the economic truth capitalism may
collapse because it does not allow the
market to tell the ecological truth so
this is our challenge to get the market
to tell the ecological truth and the the
simple way of doing it is to restructure
the tax system not change the level of
taxes but reduce the income taxes and
offset that by increasing taxes on
environmentally destructive activities
carbon emissions generation of toxic
waste use of pesticides deforestation
clear-cutting you can go down the list
make your own list and you tax the
environmentally destructive things so
that you reflect the full cost then the
economy begins to adjust and to move on
to an environmentally sustainable path
it's entirely doable if we decide we
want to do it the question is can we
move fast enough the answer is no one
knows I mean we may already have set in
motion climate changes that will not be
able to to interrupt or halt or reverse
but sometimes change comes very quickly
I remember you remember Eastern Europe
1989 1990 the Berlin Wall came down a
political revolution a bloodless
political revolution basically minor
exception Romania now interestingly you
can go back and this has been done you
can search the political science
journals during the 80s and not a single
political scientist said watch out
there's big change coming in Eastern
Europe it it was not anticipated but at
some point those societies crossed the
threshold and everyone knew that the
great social experiment socialist
experiment was over the one party
political system the centrally planned
economy was not working and everyone
knew it including the people in power
and we had enormous change I could use
another example cigarette smoking in the
United States if we've been sitting here
five years ago and I had said I think
this the the cigarette industry is is is
about to crack and and I think they're
going to reimburse state governments for
the cost of treating smoking-related
illnesses the Medicare cost of tricking
treating smoking-related illnesses to
the tune of 200 and 250 1 billion
dollars it's a thousand dollars very
personal
United States you would have asked John
Andrews your program German how I got on
the program because it was so far beyond
what anyone could imagine at that time
but two years later it happened so
social social change sometimes happens
quickly and unpredictably we cross
certain thresholds and I have a feeling
Jenna and I were talking about this a
bit earlier that we may be approaching
one of those thresholds on the
environment where change will come very
quickly regardless of who's in the White
House because it will become become
obvious things things have to change the
exciting thing is that we're now
beginning to see these changes occurring
wind turbines are replaced in coal mines
fuel cells starting to replace internal
combustion engines hydrogen generators
replacing oil refineries this is the new
world that's beginning to unfold and the
interesting thing is almost everything
we need to do to create an eco economy
that is an environmentally sustainable
economy one that can satisfy current
needs without jeopardizing the prospects
of future generations everything we need
to do to do that is being done by some
country somewhere in the world you can
see it in the wind farms and Denmark the
solar rooftops in Japan the reforest and
mountains of South Korea the irrigation
efficiencies of Israel the steel
mini-mill recycling plants now spread
all across the United States fifty-eight
percent of all steel produced in this
country last year came from scrap in
Germany seventy-two percent of all the
paper last year came from scrap if the
rest of the world just moved to the
German level and Germany is still going
up is the Western world just moved to
where Germany is today we could reduce
tree cutting in the world by one-third
so that there we can see now what needs
to be done we can see it happening in in
various places you can see it in the
netherlands in amsterdam and
and the bicycle networks you know with
with a large share of all trips now
taken in Amsterdam the same as join
copenhagen on bicycles because it's
convenient I mean they've designed the
transportation system to accommodate
bicycles in this country if you want to
get exercise on the bicycle you go to a
you drive your car to a fitness center
and then you go in and you sit on a
stationary bike for half an hour and get
a workout take a shower get in your car
and drive home something's wrong with
the system and more and more people are
beginning to realize that so change has
begun it's it's exciting and we can now
see we can visualize we can describe
with some in some detail and some
confidence what but the new economy will
look like and what life will be like I
mean can you imagine living in the city
without air pollution I mean here in
Washington as you know in the summer we
had these warnings you know if you're
elderly or young don't go outside you
know don't exercise today it's dangerous
something's wrong I mean I think I
remember being in Boston many years ago
now and I was staying at a hotel and the
conference center was several blocks
away but between no down the conference
that it was a through light we cut right
through the city and yet and to get over
yeah i mean with no lights you had to
wait until there was a break in the
traffic and sort of run across and I
remember standing there watching this
and and thinking the the noise the air
pollution the disruption of the
community and and I said to myself I
don't think this is the ultimate in
human social evolution I think we can do
better and I think in looking ahead up
at the new eco economy we can do better
we can now see how to do it that's the
exciting thing John do we have time for
questions
many of us assume that we need to face
the fact of our rampant consumerism at
least in this country and we're setting
the an example to the rest of the world
isn't a part of saving the planet not
consuming so much or do you think with
renewable energy and other tricks that
we can consume the same level I'm
probably more concerned about how we
produce the energy than how much we
consume but what I think we're going to
begin to realize is that we're consuming
more energy than is good for us I mean
what we've done basically is we've
designed an economic system and a
lifestyle that has phased out exercise
and so we now are in the midst of
literally an epidemic of obesity it
begins with kids you know and it's it's
it's a serious one and the the number of
lives the premature deaths from obesity
and the various things associated with
including diabetes before too many years
past we keep going as we are will we see
the number of lives lost to smoking
which has been the big sort of lifestyle
thing that's that's been so health
health doesn't destruct destructive in
this country what I think we will find
as we begin be thinking some of these
things is that there's more to life than
consumption and I think we've seen a bit
of this in September Elevens I think
people been taking inventory sort of it
asking themselves what is important and
they're discovering it may not be the
things that they thought were important
before so I'm guessing that that's what
we're going to see
as a renowned ecologist I would just
curious whether the government of China
invited you to look at these gigantic
damming of the Three Gorges my husband
and I were five days on the Yankee this
summer and we saw the the level of
inundation that's going to take place
and the changes that will occur putting
the people on higher levels taking them
out of their traditional farming areas
and we are some very well-informed
Chinese what they're going to do with
people who have never done any technical
skills they're all farmers and the
response to us was oh they will really
relegate them where they can find jobs
for them so were you ever asked by the
Chinese government to come and help them
out
I have to tell you a story about the
questioner we were talking earlier this
evening and she confessed that she was
actually looking for speakers for the
spouses of the of the participants in
the IMF World Bank conference and so
this is a test I'm being tested tonight
to see there are a lot of people in
China who have questions about three
gorges I think jus Ranji is one of them
and I think that because he's always
asking questions about how much does
this cost how much does that cost and
it's clear that I think he feels that
the costs are excessive I mean this is
lee palms project and he's an engineer
and it's his sort of Memorial in the
sense as a an elder statesman in the
party and the former leader it's quite
possible that the three gorges dam will
never be completed they may go part way
and not all the way because it's years
and years from completion yet and the
costs are going to be very high I have
some real doubts about the feasibility
of three gorges and I think wind would
be a far better solution maybe some
small dams and the tributaries feeding
would would make more sense another
large project that the Chinese are
considering is the south-north diversion
of water I mean there are three projects
as you know the East the central in the
Western and they're talking about
possibly going head with all three of
them to get more water to the north I
think they're much more much less costly
ways of dealing with a water problem in
the North one would be investing in
efficiency and really pushing water
efficiency
in a systemic way but to answer your
question no the Chinese did not invite
my opinion on the Three Gorges Dam they
have on some other things and regretted
it so that probably explains why i
should say to their credit though that i
did a book five or six years ago
entitled who will feed china that raised
some serious questions about China's
future food security and and the need to
likely need to import massive amounts of
grain and it created an extraordinary
stir in in China I mean I won't try to
describe it all but I I had not fully
appreciated the sensitivity of the issue
I knew about the Great Famine of 1959-60
oh I mean intellectually I knew that and
knew it well what I had not fully
appreciated is that all the leaders in
beijing today are survivors of that
famine and so to them food security is
not a trivial issue and the idea that
they might become heavily dependent on
the outside world and therefore heavily
dependent on the United States was
politically anathema and so almost every
week for a year or two after I published
that book there was a new study released
in China explaining why I was mistaken
unfortunately I think I may be closer to
the mark them than they wanted to admit
at the time I'm pleased to say that this
book is being sponsored and and my visit
there probably in May will be sponsored
by government agencies so this is I find
encouraging they know they've got
problems and and they invited me there
actually a year and a half after I did
who will feed China to discuss the the
issues but they didn't ask me about
three gorges
what is your feeling about the Kyoto
Protocol that's treated so dismissively
by the administration and the
legislature do you have to use on that
I'm sure you did yeah the I think was a
big mistake for the administration to
just reject the protocol it's not
terribly ambitious it only involves an
industrial country of seven percent
reduction in carbon emissions or
something like that over the next decade
or so my guess is that events will
overtake the Kyoto Protocol within the
next few years and that things will be
happening on the climate front whether
it's record heat waves or some ice
melting or new evidence of more rapid
ice melting droughts crop failures I
sense that within the next few years
keeping in mind that last year was the
second warmest on record so we're on a
very clear trend there's a chart of that
in the book I would guess a few years
from now we'll be scrambling on this
issue everyone will be because well
it'll be clear that things are going to
have to change change quickly
yes what impact if any does the current
medical establishment and health care
industry have on the things you're
talking about thank you for that
question that's a big one one of the
keys to slowing population growth in the
developing countries is getting health
care and family planning services and
literacy especially for females into
developing countries and my colleague
Janet Larson recently published a piece
on Iran fascinating what's happening in
Iran in recent years you may remember
when the Ayatollah took over in 1978 I
think it was so I mean I one of the
first things he did was dismantle the
family planning programs at the shot put
in place one of the one of the good
things to Shah and done and he said what
we need in Iran quote are more babies
more babies more babies in order to
compete with a decadent West and they
actively encouraged women to have more
more babies the fertility rate went up
the population growth went up to four
point two percent per year which is
pretty close to the biological maximum
and after several years of this they
began to look around and realize that
they were headed for trouble I mean the
country was largely deforested over
grazing was everywhere soil erosion was
a problem water tables are falling and
suddenly they began to realize I had to
change and they did and they began by
setting up rural clinics across the
country health / family planning clinics
like 17,000 of them and did it very
quickly they raised female literacy in
rural areas where seventy or eighty
percent of people in they raised it from
something like twenty five percent to
eighty-five percent in a matter of years
and today this year last year actually
the population growth rate in Iran
only slightly higher than in the United
States and this is in a country with
very strong undertones of Islamic
fundamentalism as you know so when I
look at at the health community I think
about population and the conditions that
will lead to smaller families and that
means basic health care and access to
family planning services what do you see
in terms of trends are people listening
more to you and you publish books but is
that sufficient oars or other ways to
get changes made I think what we're
faced with is an enormous educational
problem because the circumstances in
which we live are changing throughout
most of human existence we could not
have much effect on the climate system
for example I mean there weren't enough
of us we couldn't affect the Earth's
forests cover I mean we could cut and
burn a few trees here and there but we
were so few compared with the size of
the planet that's all changed now the
economy is six times as big now as it
was in nineteen fifty the world's
population is more than twice as big I
mean when you think about it when we say
that world population is more than
doubled since 1950 that's the same as
saying there's been more population
growth in the world since 1950 and
during the preceding four million years
when we first stood up right I mean you
know in our lifetimes we've seen more
population growth than the West
throughout all of human existence up
until then so we I don't think we've yet
grasped the consequences of things like
population growth adding 80 million
people here or the buildup in greenhouse
gases and and and the change in the
Earth's climate we are the first
generation who have the capacity to
quite literally alter the world in which
our children will live we can change the
climate for example
that's that's new so it's it's it's
partly educational trying to get help
people understand I mean trying to
understand ourselves I mean I have the
luxury of spending all my time thinking
about these issues and I still you know
there's a lot that I don't understand so
it's a complex set of issues and from an
analytical point of view we're dealing
with the interaction between three
systems each of which is very complex in
its own right we're looking at an
economic system we're looking at a at an
ecosystem and we're looking at a
political system that governs or at
least should govern the relationship
between the economic system and the and
the ecosystem and we have three systems
interacting all the time and trying to
understand what's happening in each of
those systems and the interactions among
the three of them and it's it's it's
complex there's no way we can model this
it's just far beyond any computer
modeling capability we can do bits and
pieces of it reasonably well but we
can't put it all together it's just so
so complex so it's trying to distill the
essence of this out so it's
understandable we can we can see at
least some of the consequences of
continuing on the path we're now on and
trying to trying to convince ourselves
that we need to make some basic course
corrections how much effect is one have
I mean it's a question that's it's an
interesting one I mean you can look at
news clips you can look at you know
recent how many emails you get or how
many languages your books are translated
into I mean a lot of sort of
intermediate indicators but in the end
it's only the changes that that count I
mean I mentioned the book i did on who
will feed china just a site one specific
example as a result of that book the
national intelligence council here in
Washington which is the umbrella over
all the intelligence agency CIA dia
National Security Agency and the
individual Armed Forces has their own
intelligence agent is over the mall
after I did who will feed China and
pointed out the likelihood that before
too long China would be forced into the
world market on a scale that would
disrupt world grain markets drive prices
up potentially off the top of the chart
and create political instability in
low-income developing countries that
depend on imported grain because they
could couldn't be able to afford to
import enough and that became a security
issue and the national intelligence
council launched a study the most
comprehensive detailed study of the
future of Chinese agriculture ever
undertaken using CIA satellite images on
land used modeling every River Basin in
China of current and projected future
supply and demand it was headed by
Michael McElroy at Harvard who heads the
Department of Earth and Planetary
Sciences I think it's called but this
was a huge volume I've seen only in an
executive summary / that was cleared for
official use only and and the Chinese
government itself contributed data to to
that that study because they were
concerned about it but it's by far the
most detail and they concluded as I did
that china is going to be driven into
the world market for massive amounts of
grain within the next few decades to
stay with china for a minute the
traditional model has been that as
countries develop economically the birth
rate declines family size declines in a
country like china where you've had
already a government-imposed policy
restricting family size what does this
phenomenal economic growth
mean for consumerism for example is all
the sort of energy economic energy
instead of being transmitted over a
whole generation and reducing family
size going to be imposed immediately or
directly on consumer as and and we have
or do we have the prospect of a China
several billion people consuming at a
rate comparable to what we are of this
country if I understand your question
that was China could have had many many
more people or they could move up the
food chain with food for example and
consume much more individually and one
of the things that has made the enormous
economic growth possible in China of the
last few decades is they've had a very
low dependency ratio that is with small
families I mean the goal was one in many
cases the reality is as close to two on
average but nonetheless that was a
dramatic drop so for for for these last
two decades they've had a large number
of able-bodied workers of working age
with a very small dependency ratio
because there were that many children
and there weren't that many elderly at
either so so we had a workforce that was
totally I mean we had a population
totally dominated by the labor force
there weren't many too young to work
about 90 too old to work so that was an
ideal situation for breaking out of
poverty and getting things along there
now beginning to develop problems with
growing numbers of aging of course but
the in the end we have to we have the
limit
that the pressure on resources whether
it comes from population growth or
rising affluence really on previous
question I think you would agree that
most that pauses for environmental
science and schools is perfunctory I
think it's fair to say that in Texas one
of the more environmentally minded
states twenty-five percent of students
actually take a course of all
environmental science so my custom user
is what if you could you do or have done
or might do it to improve the quality of
environmental science in schools and if
we put environmental science the place
it obviously deserves not just to make
students environmentally aware but
environmental in knowledgeable what are
we going to take out of the curriculum
it's already overcrowded that's my
question probably English I would say I
mean we have to set priorities at some
point I don't know it's an interesting
question and how its taught in it you
know at what stage and what form one of
the interesting things is that
environmental science taught properly is
going to be a value changing experience
and and that I mean that's happened
already I mean how many parents have I
heard say you know Johnny came home
schooler or Betty came home from school
and said hey mom you can't do that you
know you've got to do this I mean kids
got it boo fest I remember a
conversation with Ted Turner wants about
this about education and I said you know
it's going to be difficult because we
have to teach a generate trainer
generation of teachers they have to
teach a generation of kids who a
generation later become the
decision-makers I said but by that time
the game may be over and he said I think
you're right and he thought about it for
a while and he came up with the idea of
developing cartoon programs and going
directly to the kids called captain
I remember him calling me once it's
probably been a dozen years ago after
this he said we've got captain planet
going he said it's now going in 77
countries and he started through the
list Argentina you know and down the
list I mean Ted gets excited he gets
excited and oh he said and by the way
I'm now engaged to Jane Fonda that was
kind of secondary when it I remember a
conversation i had with less number of
years ago about the fact that Earth Day
is celebrated on april twenty second and
i pointed out that if they simply moved
in one day later to april twenty third
we could combine forces and have
shakespeare's earth day but as i thought
more about it it occurred to me that
there's an even better reason for that
which is that april twenty third is st.
George's Day and George derives from the
Greek word that means earth worker and I
would say that if there is a saint
george among us today it would be Lester
Brown less thank you so nice
one more book story some of you will
recognize the name will durant wrote a
13 volume work on the history of the
world or something like that many 30 40
years ago will durant was a graduate
student at Columbia University and he
had the rare good fortune of having his
doctoral dissertation published as a
book and a couple of years later he got
word from his publisher mcgraw-hill that
it was no longer selling and they were
going to remainder it but that they had
nine hundred copies left and if he
wanted he could have them so he was
living in northern New Jersey the
mcgraw-hill warehouse was in northern
New Jersey so he and his wife Ariel
who'd been one of his graduate students
got in their Model T and drove up and in
their house they had a study it was
lined with bookshelves he had about 100
books of his own he put in they
proceeded to fill the study with these
nine hundred copies of the book and some
time later he was writing to a friend in
Europe and he said Ariel and I are
settled down housekeeping he said we're
enjoying life he's in by the way said I
have a library of a thousand volumes 900
of which I've written myself
now lest I end up with such a library
the books are on sale in the back of ten
dollars of coffee
Lester Brown is the founder and chairman
of the worldwatch institute as well as
senior author of the state of the world
report his book eco economy building an
economy for the earth is published by
Norton for more information visit their
website w Norton com